so
before i lose you for time i just have
to ask you about your franchise because
i know you probably don't think of
yourself as a guy who has a franchise
foot locker
but
i just feel like your franchise which is
great to have a franchise and yours is a
great one because it was a great show
yeah you did it in the 90s you rebooted
it
a few years ago yeah there's been two
movies yeah
you're gonna do it again
and you should do it again right because
it's
because
it's uh
it's a great show very entertaining
you're great in it and it's ever more
relevant well there's not a day that
goes by i don't read about some now it's
congress looking into it the pentagon's
looking into it they're all saying
now what they call them unidentified
aerial phenomenon because ufo wasn't
good yeah
they're rebranding why it's the same
[ __ ] thing did i ever tell you my my
theory of the ufos no you might like
this i know we're out of time or
whatever no
um
it seemed to me
do you remember you know the phenomenon
of like ship of fools back back in the
medieval times they didn't really have
prisons built or insane assignments
built it was before that no i didn't
read that book so well
the idea was like sometimes they would
take their criminal offenders or their
insane people put them on a ship and
send them out like we don't want to deal
with you anymore we're going to put you
out on the high seas and and woe be to
you if you come upon this ship of fools
that's what ship with fools is when you
hear that so i think because
people that have dealings with aliens
that we that tell us stories usually
they get their teeth drilled
and their anuses probed so
so my
my theory is that some alien some
advanced alien civilization has gotten
fed up with their sex offenders and
their dentists
[Applause]
and they put them on an intergalactic
ship sent them out into the great sea of
the beyond of the galaxies and sometimes
they come around us
or it's just their dentist and it's a
very deep cavity
but
perhaps
perhaps their anatomies are different
from ours and they get confused well we
know what they look like because they
all do look the same when people you
know
so i don't know but when navy pilots
are saying i can't tell you what this
thing is and neil degrasse tyson was
here and of course
utmost respect
knows things i will never know or i
could never know i don't have that size
brand okay so he pooh-poohed the idea
that it's aliens
yeah he said why did they just reveal
themselves to navy pellets well it took
me a year neil degrasse but i figured
out what is it
oh i forgot
because that's who they're worried about
might be opposing them if they're casing
us to attack okay what do they give a
[ __ ] about some of the guy in peoria
he's not going to fire a squirrel gun at
them they're they're okay these are the
people they might have to go against so
they're seeing what they can do what
they can see that's why they reveal
themselves to navy pilots
you